but first
i'm joined by the chair of the
conservative party oliver down and good
morning mr dowden good morning um
can we just start with the issue that i
think will still concern most people in
this country
is omicron in retreat
well we've seen some very promising data
whether that's in relation to infections
or hospitalizations and that of course
hasn't happened by accident it's
happened because so many people have
taken that booster vaccine and thanks
the drive we gave it before christmas
we've now got over 60 of the total
population covered with the booster
vaccine and actually over 90 of over 50.
so that gives us
pause for hope and optimism that we may
be emerging from the worst of omicron so
it is it is good news but it's thanks to
all that hard work that has happened
should we then expect the lifting of the
restrictions when the review comes in 10
days time
well it's always been my hope that we
would have the plan b restrictions for
the shortest period possible i'm under
no doubt the kind of burdens this puts
hospitality wider business schools and
so on under and i want us to to get rid
of those if we possibly can the signs
are encouraging but clearly they will
wait to see the data ahead of that final
decision but the likelihood is that that
is what will happen those restrictions
will be lifted unless we see something
surprising in the data well it all seems
to be heading in the right direction
particularly crucially in relation to
hospitalizations which seem to be
plateauing you've seen those very good
headline numbers it's heading in the
right direction now i'm very hopeful and
optimistic but clearly we'll await the
data at the point of the decision before
making that final decision let me ask
you about another big challenge facing
government mr putin
has essentially brewed
uh a rather dangerous situation on the
border with ukraine he's got a hundred
thousand troops there waiting for his
orders um negotiations in vienna this
week basically drew a blank what's
government doing to avoid war
well
it is important that we have that kind
of engagement that we saw in vienna and
we were represented by minister cleverly
at that we continue to work with the
united states and with our allies and we
need to continue to be robust as we have
been in saying to russia that if it
infringes on the sovereignty of the
ukraine it will face severe consequences
we need to be united in sending that
message and we are what do severe
consequences
look like i mean
what does that mean well we have said
there'll be severe economic consequences
sanctions regimes and so on where that
tap and russia needs to be in no doubt
at all that we would not allow this to
happen without those those consequences
clearly the defense secretary has said
this is a different matter given that
ukraine isn't a member of nato when it
comes to direct western military
intervention but nonetheless we will be
very robust in our our action i know
that president biden is very much
committed to that and of course he has
been in touch with prime minister boris
johnson about that
look i've asked you about two major
challenges facing the government i could
equally have asked about the cost of
living and the energy prices or brexit
and northern ireland or the ballooning
fiscal deficit or about the chinese
communist party's influence infiltration
of parliament yet all of that is being
dwarfed this morning
and day after day by the series of
revelations about conduct in number 10
downing street
and by the way the conduct of prime
minister and mrs
johnson
when do you plan to tell boris johnson
that if the conservative party is to
lead us through these challenges
uh
he can no longer be prime minister you
can't afford him anymore
well i don't agree with that analysis i
think boris johnson should of course
remain as our prime minister and i'll
tell you why it's precisely for the
conversation we're just having now it
was the prime minister that made that
call about having the mass booster
program which is ensured we're getting
through the worst form of crime at the
same time he made the call despite the
huge pressure and you may have
remembered this i recall it around
having a further lockdown in the face of
that omicron variant he made the right
call and has meant that we've managed to
have the most open economy in europe and
the most vast economy in europe the two
are linked together and i think when it
comes to those big calls he's made the
right call now of course i don't
diminish for a second that the kind of
events that we've seen were totally
wrong i was angered by them my
constituents were angered by them the
whole country was angered by them and
it's absolutely right the prime minister
said we'll get to the bottom of them and
i'll tell you that when he responds to
the house of commons this is committed
to doing so he will make sure that we
address the kind of culture that has
allowed that to happen in the first
place it's going to have to be a pretty
dramatic response i mean
at the very least
your job is to get the conservative
party back into government
you've
turned an 80-seat majority two years ago
into what is now a consistent
10
deficit in the polls and that is down to
mr johnson he is the obstacle
to your doing your job
well
we all know that opinion polls vary what
matters to me well what matters what
matters to the british system what
matters to the british people is first
of all they rightly expect us to get a
grip of this situation it was totally
wrong the the events that happened it's
absolutely right the premises apologize
and he will need to take further steps
and he will take those further steps
when he makes a statement to the house
of commons but it is also the case that
we need to address not just covered and
thank goodness we're making progress as
we come out of omicron but also on the
consequences of covid whether that's
clearing the nhs backlog or whether
that's rebuilding the economy we need
that kind of leadership to get us
through it and that's what people expect
of course we take these things seriously
and we must address them but we must
also address the consequences of what
could he possibly say about what we
already know has taken place
that would change opinions about that
culture you yourself mentioned
downing street uh and in whitehall i
mean what could he possibly say well of
course it's important that we first get
to the facts of everything that happened
now the prime minister has already
apologized in respect of one event that
that happened we need to get all the
facts that's what sue gray's doing
through her report we need to look at
how that stacks up against the rules at
the time and the prime minister needs to
respond to that now you won't expect me
to get into the detail of that response
but i can tell you from the many
conversations i've had with the prime
minister and what you saw from him in
the house on wednesday is that he is
committed to upping our game we must
improve the culture we must do better i
hear people's anger i know it and we've
got to respond to that yeah but you know
he himself said at pmq's there was a
party i was there i mean we don't need
two greater tanners so tim one of your
own mps uh tim london this morning has
made that point we don't need to know
what sue gray might or might not have
found in the in the dusty files or from
some junior employees he's told us
himself
well i think it's important to
understand what the the sioux grain
inquiry is doing it's not just in
relation to
the event that happened i believe on the
20th of may it first of all looks at the
range of events where there's been
speculation about what may have happened
but in addition to that crucially it
also
allows people to come forward and bring
forward any further allegations so they
can properly be examined once we've got
a full picture of the facts
independently that will then allow the
prime minister to respond to it now of
course that is going to require a change
of culture and i know that the prime
minister is committed to leading that
and i know that the prime minister
feels a sincere sense of regret and has
apologized profoundly for what happened
and that is genuine but i think people
need to hear that in response in the
statement that he will make in response
to the sugree report
look you know we can
bandy
words about what sugray may or may not
produce she can't do anything about it
actually because all you can do is say
what the facts are in the end in the
slightly bizarre situation it's the
prime minister himself who will decide
whether he the prime minister has broken
the ministerial code i mean that's
another piece of madness which we can
return to another time but
i want to take you on to if you like the
the larger issue here which we know
about um
because there's a lot that we already
know and forgive me if i'm going to take
a bit of time to lay this out
we know that 16th of april 2021 night
before prince philip's funeral two boozy
parties
18th december 2020 cheese and wine night
days after london went into tier three
16th of december 20th 2020 15 december
2020 14th december 2020 conservative
party headquarters
party in the basement i think 10th of
december party at department for
education they've owned up to that
parties 27th of november 2020 25th
november 2020 13th november 2020
20th of may 2020 prime minister spoke
about it this week make the most of the
lovely weather
prime minister finally admitted to
joining that party himself the 15th of
may 2020. these are the things we
already know about we don't have to have
a civil servant to tell us about them
by the way there's every friday friday
wine time now it's taken me ages
to set that out you're the party
chairman there were a lot of parties
all the while people
in their thousands were sticking to the
rules
and your people
were breaking them
one word
shameful right just shameful
yes it was completely unacceptable that
this happened
i i feel like i'm accepting a political
word i feel i feel i feel i'm happy to
use
whichever adjectives
you choose to express my anger at what
happened i'm angry about what happened
the prime minister is angry about what
happened it should not have happened
there needs to be a change in the
culture but what i would say to you is
that it is important and it's right to
ensure that we find the full facts of
what happened of course we've seen some
of it and we can go through the detail
of each one of them but we need to get
that full picture which will then enable
the prime minister to respond
effectively he will make a statement to
parliament he'll be held accountable in
parliament for his actions i think that
that is the proper and right process and
i don't for a minute
uh step back or resile
from the the sense of anger that people
feel about this the question is what do
we do now we need to find out the facts
and then the prime minister needs to
respond effectively and to address the
culture in downing street and i know
that he is committed to doing that
look i i know this is your job to come
on and defend him but you know it feels
like the prime minister's um himself is
part of the culture and
if i may say everybody thinks you're a
decent
bloke you're an honorable person
on that 20th of may
you were at the podium in downing street
giving the downing street briefing
telling us in good faith that we were
not permitted to meet more than one
other person outside our household
one hour later prime ministers out there
in the party i mean
he has made an absolute mug of you
personally i mean don't you feel
how can you defend this
well i'm not seeking to defend it and
nor is the prime minister and if you
look at what he said to the house of
commons on wednesday he gave a sincere
apology for what happened he gave an
explanation for for what had happened it
should not have happened and that was a
failure and he has in credit to the
prime minister
owned up to that the question for us now
is how we go broader than just this and
look at the wider cultural issues but
there's also a wider question about
given where we are with omicron as we
emerge
what do we need to do and i think
alongside addressing this we need to
address the consequences of covert
whether that's rebuilding the economy
whether that's cost of living whether
that is clearing the nhs backlog and we
also need to get that focus on that and
i know the prime minister is committed
to doing so
look let me uh
you know in the old days people would
have resigned by now wouldn't they i
mean but let's just deal
if i with a specific example because i
think
you've given me the answers that i guess
you have to give but i wonder if
the government really understands
what this anger is about let's take the
weekend of april 16th 17th and 18th last
year
let me remind you what took place
on that saturday there was her majesty
queen
isolated at the funeral of her husband
of 70 years she's unable to sit with her
own family
uh if you don't and let's not split
hairs about the regulations about the
sugray and all that kind of stuff
but
most of the country was thinking about
this that weekend
and i just wonder what kind of people
have not just one but two boozy farewell
parties on the friday night
before this happens
i mean
when you have to go into dining street
meet these people morally how do you
how do you feel about that
well first of all we
all
shared and respected the tremendous
dignity and selflessness that the queen
showed on on this occasion as she has
done throughout her reign and i was
disgusted at the fact that there were
parties taking place before this
profound event of national mourning in
our nation's history it shouldn't have
happened
and it was wrong
that they have already apologized for
doing so
it was just plain wrong and it shouldn't
have happened but but the point i'm
making to you trevor is that we i think
in order to move on from this we first
of all need to establish the full facts
of what happened at all the different
uh alleged events that that took place
and that's the purpose of the sugray
inquiry the next step is then the prime
minister to come to the house of commons
to give a full response to be held to
account for that but i can tell you that
the prime minister is genuinely
committed
both in demonstrating his remorse and
apology for what happened but also in
taking steps to ensure that we address
the kind of culture in downing street
that enabled something like that to
happen which clearly should never have
happened in the first place
but i suppose what i'm really trying to
get at mr dowden is that i understand
the process and all of that
but
i i just wonder whether prime minister
or you really understand that that
process however clean it is
not going to answer
the question that is being asked out
there in the country and uh if you'll
forgive me i i've um
talked about this once before on this
program and i i hope never hoped never
to have to do it again but
uh
i think there are thousands millions of
people across the country who will feel
frankly rather as i do let's go back to
that april
17th 18th weekend and i just want to say
something about
what i did that during the week and i
think other people have exactly the same
story that week
i saw my two daughters at various times
outside
one was pregnant one was very ill their
mother stepmother and i weren't allowed
to meet them together
we all stuck to the spirit and the
letter the rules
on the saturday after watching the
funeral of prince philip i went to one
of my friend's
70th birthday parties
he'd hired a tent
he's got loads of friends but he's had a
tent for just six of us so we could sit
outside
he stuck to the spirit and the letter of
the rules
at that dinner i get a call my
daughter's collapsed and as you will
know
for months she'd
you know she'd been isolated she was ill
by the following morning
she had died and she had stuck to the
spirit
and let her the rules now there are
going to be thousands of people who have
that story
in their
background
and if i may say so
you are in here telling me about a civil
servant's inquiry that will not answer
that
anger
what is does the prime minister really
understand
why people are angry
well first of all i know how much you
have suffered during this period and i
know how much so many people in this
country have suffered the probations
that they have been subject to the
steadfastness with which people obeyed
the rules and it is totally wrong if
there has been any way in which and
we've seen some examples of this those
rules have not been
fully obeyed in downing street what i'm
trying to
offer to you and to your viewers who may
be watching this program
is to explain to you how the government
is seeking to move forward through this
first of all to establish all of the
facts of what happened and then the
prime minister
will be held to account in parliament
for what happened and i want to assure
you
and i want to assure any of your viewers
listening i've discussed it with the
prime minister on many occasions he has
a sincere sense of remorse and regret at
what happened
as do i as to other members of the
government all right look let me go so
forgive me let me get back to actually
doing my job here but the truth of the
matter still is the politics of this are
that you're facing a consistent poll
deficit biggest in 88 years
and in reality you know what the most
decisive thing you as party chair could
do about this so let me just ask you
again
when are you going to tell the prime
minister that he himself is the
principal object
that stands in the way of your doing
your job successfully which is to get
the conservative party re-elected to
government well i do not believe that
the prime minister should resign for the
the reasons that we have discussed in
this interview i do though think it is
essential that we address the kind of
failings that allow this to happen that
the prime minister is held to account
for what happened and addresses that in
parliament and that we also
build on the kind of work that we have
done with the vaccine rollout program to
address the subsequent challenges of
covert whether that's clearing the nhs
backlog or rebuilding the economy i
think that that is the right approach
rather than going through a period of
divisive uh leadership contests which
is not the sense that i get of what
british people want us to be focusing on
they want us to focus on the job at hand
of dealing with omicron and then the
consequences of covert
oligarchs thank you very much